so Marvel Studios is in a really weird
situation right now
they have movies that are being filmed
and talked about and have already been
officially announced that have to do
with characters that died in Avengers
infinity war real quick there are some
spoilers coming up so you've been warned
[Music]
and also a reminder that I am doing a
giveaway right now I'm giving away a few
copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero
so they're trying not to give away any
spoilers about characters in Avengers 4
but they're also trying to promote new
movies like Spider Man far from home so
it's a little hard not to say that all
these characters that died in Avengers
infinity war are coming back because
that's what everyone believes right now
so there are obviously a ton of reasons
that we could list of why the Avengers
will be coming back in Avengers 4 the
directors however have not said anything
actually what they have said is quite
the opposite they want us to believe
that all the characters that died in an
Avengers infinity war are actually
permanently dead but obviously none of
us believe that especially when you have
spider-man far from home filming right
now and the directors and producers can
say whatever they want they can say oh
well this is actually it's still a
sequel to homecoming but it actually
takes place before the events of
infinity war okay sure you can say that
but we don't believe it I don't believe
you
but still no one has actually said
anything about the characters coming
back in Avengers 4 not the producers not
the directors not the actors until now
in a recent interview with good morning
Britain dave bautista dropped some
spoilers on us for Avengers 4
franchise as well yeah are we gonna see
any more Doge I believe so yeah we
definitely see more Guardians and the
upcoming Avengers which we've already
shot it you know I I guess I wasn't
supposed to say anything but I was
already saying before the Guardians
three-arm sorry Avengers 3 was released
that I had already filmed for yes and I
was signed up for guardians 3 so yeah
I've shot scenes in it so uh yeah but at
the same time I felt a sense of guilt
because I don't know if I was supposed
to say anything and nobody told me not
this should be ferried anacondas too it
says God in three will return this
interview is actually kind of hilarious
to me dave bautista just seems like a
logical guy he's basically saying hey
guys I told you before infinity war even
came out that I've shot scenes for
Avengers four so clearly I'm in Avengers
four in the middle of this while I'm
breaking it down huh did you hear what I
said
stop was me after you so do we need a
plan
not to mention I signed up for guardians
3 so I clearly come back somehow it's
also really funny to me because he
clearly didn't get the memo that nobody
was supposed to say anything but again I
think he just thought in his head well
it's just kind of common sense that
we're going to come back so this is the
first official time that anybody from
Marvel Studios has said that the Fallen
Avengers from Avengers infinity war it
will be coming back and Avengers 4 again
we kind of all already knew this but
it's nice to have somebody officially
come out and say it I also love how
casually he just dropped this huge
spoiler of Avengers 4 just like it was
no big deal but hey that's his style
so let me know what you all think about
this in the comments below and again
another reminder about the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you so much for watching my
video Wolf Wolf
[Music]